Good afternoon,
and welcome to this very special session.
I'm Alexander Rudensky from Memorial Sloan Kettering
Cancer Center in New York.
And it is my distinct honor and
pleasure to introduce the recipient of this
year's AACR Cancer Research Institute
Lloyd J. Old Award
for Cancer Immunology.
But before I do this, let me first introduce Dr.
Alicia Zhu,
the CEO of the Cancer Research Institute, whose
generous support makes this award possible. Dr.
Zhu, please come to the podium.
Hi, everyone. It's great to see everyone. My name is Alicia Zhu.
I am the CEO for the Cancer Research Institute.
It's a pleasure to join you here at ACR.
We always love being a part of this meeting.
Every year, we've had the privilege to award the AACR CRI Lloyd
J. Old Award in Cancer Immunology.
It's actually named in honor of Dr. Lloyd J.
Old, who was our founding scientific and medical director at CRI,
and really one of the true architects of modern tumor immunology.
This award really celebrates scientists whose discoveries have fundamentally
advanced our understanding of the immune system's role in cancer.
And so I'm very excited that today we're honoring Dr.
Ken Murphy, whose pioneering work has reshaped how we understand dendritic
cells and the immune orchestration required for effective anti-tumor
responses. But I also feel like we have to
also recognize Dr. Rudensky, who chaired this year's
award selection committee. As you all already know, Dr.
Rudensky is one of the world's most influential immunologists.
His discoveries transformed our understanding of immune tolerance through defining
the biology of regulatory T cells and elucidating the
central role of the transcription factor FoxP3.
In doing so, he revealed how the immune system maintains balance, how it defends
us with precision while avoiding destructive self-reactivity.
At Memorial Sloan Kettering, Dr. Rudensky has built a body of work that continues
to shape the field, illuminating how regulatory T cells develop, adapt,
and function across infection, inflammation, and cancer.
We are very proud to have him as a member of the CRI family.
He serves as a member of our Scientific Advisory Council, and in 2015, he was
also the recipient of CRI's William B.
Coley Award
in recognition of his landmark contributions to immunology.
So it's my great pleasure to reintroduce Dr.
Rudensky so that he can introduce this year's honoree.
Thank you, Dr. Zhu.
On behalf of the officers and directors of the
AACR, we are grateful to you and
your colleagues at the Cancer Research Institute for your
continued partnership, and to CRI for the generous
support of this very special and highly
prestigious award.
As Dr. Zhu already said, this award is named in
honor of a late Dr.
Lloyd J. Old,
whom I was privileged to have as
a colleague and to know personally for
many years. Dr. Old, a pioneer
of cancer immunology, has been recognized rightfully
as the father of the field. He trained and
influenced a great many of its current leaders and
established the discipline of cancer immunotherapy, which has
since become transformative for both clinical cancer
care and for cancer research. Dr. Old served as
founder
and scientific director of the Cancer Research Institute for 40
years.
The AACR CRI Lloyd J. Old
Award in Cancer Immunology recognizes active
scientists whose outstanding and innovative
research has made a major impact on the field and has the
potential to stimulate exciting new discoveries and
directions in cancer immunology.
This year's honoree is a truly exceptional
scientist whose work has fundamentally
advanced our understanding of immunity.
The 2026 AACR Cancer Research
Institute Lloyd J. Old Award in Cancer Immunology is
presented to Dr. Kenneth Murphy, the Allen
A. and Edith L. Wolf Distinguished Professor of
Pathology and Immunology and Professor of Medicine
at Washington University School of Medicine
in St. Louis. Over the course of his career, Dr.
Murphy has made fundamental contributions to understanding
how immune responses are generated and directed,
and his discoveries have had a broad and lasting
impact on the field of cancer immunology.
Early in his career,
Dr. Murphy defined the molecular mechanisms controlling T helper
cell differentiation and the specific character of
adaptive immune responses. He helped elucidate
how distinct T helper cell fates are determined
and revealed key role for cytokines such as
interleukin-12
and for transcription factors, including STAT4, in
driving type one T helper cell differentiation.
These discoveries uncovered how instructive signals
from innate immune cells govern the qualityOf the immune
response and provided a unifying framework for
understanding how immune responses are tailored
to specific challenges, including cancer.
In a remarkable second phase of his career, Dr.
Murphy turned his focus to myeloid cell biology,
including macrophages, but foremost, dendritic cells, where
he has made equally transformative contributions.
His landmark discoveries revealed the transcriptional mechanisms controlling
the differentiation of principal dendritic cell types,
and through generational foundational genetic models,
he elucidated their functions.
The studies revolutionized cancer immunology and the broader field of
immunology. His work established one
particular subset of dendritic cells, CDC1s, as
essential mediators of antigen cross-presentation and
critical drivers of anti-tumor immunity.
Importantly, Dr. Murphy's discoveries have directly
informed translational advances in cancer immunotherapy,
including understanding of mechanisms of action of immunomodulatory
therapeutics and the development of novel cancer vaccine
approaches designed to engage CDC1s and
other dendritic cell subsets for optimal
and
anti-tumor T cell priming.
Beyond his
research contributions and accomplishments, Dr.
Murphy is widely recognized for his mentorship and
his contributions to immunology education.
Since 2005,
he has served as lead author of the renowned
immunology Janeway Immunobiology textbook,
which can be viewed as a immunologist Bible,
shaping the training of generations of scientists and clinicians.
Dr. Murphy has received numerous honors, including William B.
Coley Award for Distinguished Research in Basic and Tumor Immunology, and
American Association of Immunologists Meritorious Career Award, and he
is elected member of National Academy of Sciences.
It is my great honor to introduce the 2026
recipient of the AACR Cancer Research Institute
Lloyd J. Old Award in Cancer Immunology, Dr. Kenneth Murphy.
Well, thank you very much. I want to start by saying how appreciative
and humbled I am to have received this award.
I
want to thank the AACR and the CRI, Sasha,
and the committee, and everyone else,
Dr. Joe,
for this award. Now, awards.
When I got the email that I was coming to San Diego to receive an
award,
I thought, "What better way to encapsulate it?"
However,
here's how I really feel.
No one gets an award for something they did on their own, unless it's a sporting
event.
And it's
not just a sporting event. It would have to be track and field or something where
an individual does something remarkable.
So you might think this guy here is the superstar of surfers, but
here's what the reality of research is.
It's really a complete cooperative effort
by numbers of people, and everyone rides their own
wave, and none of us really deserve any kind of call-out
for anything special. So this award
really belongs to all of the participants, and
contributors to the work over many years.
This would be a list of the people who are currently in the lab.
I'll talk about Sue and Joe and Ray O'Hara's work today.
And
it's also built upon some past trainees, and they're listed here.
This is a recent set of past trainees.
There are lots of people who worked on this,
and it continues to go back. And our work in the dendritic cell area
really didn't start until about 2006 when this
Dr. Kai Hildner came to the lab and came up with
the finding that made the Batf3 mouse, which
was a finding that redirected our efforts from
one area to the other. And then, of course, I have to say that I've been
really fortunate to be at Washington University,
where an enormous number of very collegial and
excellent colleagues have also contributed to the work.
And I'd note Will Gail Anders and Bob Schreiber among
the most important of these.
I also want to call a shout-out. I promised Tim Eberline that I would
also note that we have a fantastic Siteman Cancer Center at
WashU that Tim initiated and
spearheaded and ran for a number of years.
And he gave me a whole slide deck, which I won't
show you. Now, in terms of the question we've been asking
for many, many years is how does the adaptive immune system
direct the quality of its
response to deal with a number of different pathogens?
And this is my favorite first slide.
You have a number of different modules within the adaptive immune
system and within the innate immune system.
And our early work talked about how do you
convince a CD4 T cell to take on different personalities that
would direct it to either combating intracellular
pathogens, extracellular pathogens, or
parasites like a Th2 response. And we worked on that for a number of
years and came up with a number of explanations, which
usually involved a particular inducing
cytokine acting through a certain transcriptional pathway to
redirect the differentiation of the CD4 T cell down the appropriate
path to lead to the response that's most appropriate for the
inciting pathogen.And I just want to show this
now, after all of this time, here's basically what we've come
up with when you add the dendritic cell field to it.
We have
cells at the top, the DC1, that can make the IL-12 under
the right conditions to drive the CD4 to the TH1
pathway. And we're in the process of working out the DC2
heterogeneity. It's not a complete story yet, but we have lots of
findings. There are DC2 subsets that make cytokines
appropriate to drive a TH17 response.
A little bit of a mystery of how they drive a TH2 response, but
this is ongoing work. And these are important because they
direct
the innate response. The dendritic cell subsets are
interpreting their exposure to pathogen to direct the
appropriate eventual adaptive immune response.
And important for the tumor immunity part of this, the DC1
turns out to be an important subset
operating under viral infections or tumors
to
carry on a process called cross-presentation.
So I want to show just a few slides to explain how did we get
to this model system.
And I'll start by going back to Kai Hildner in 2006,
when he stumbled literally across this small
family of AP-1 family members,
AP-1
and Fos and Jun, but there were these small
proteins, well they weren't even called BATF at the time.
They had a Ryken clone number. And we noticed that
they had an interesting pattern of expression.
And
back in the day when you took
several maybe up to a year to make a targeted ES cell
and get some mice out of it, Kai Hildner screened about
1,600 individual ES cell clones by Southern
blot and finally came up with a Batf3 mouse, which he
studied for six months trying to look for an EAE phenotype of which
there is none, and eventually came to look at the
dendritic cell subset. And
we soon saw that something was missing
and I asked, "What are those cells?" And they turn out
to be dendritic cells, which are cells which Ralph Steinman had
described in the '70s. So for reasons that we didn't
understand at the time, the Batf3 knockout lacked DC1s.
With help from a variety of colleagues, including Bob Schreiber, we
examined their antiviral and antitumor immune responses, and you can see
that the lack of Batf3 in the mouse
made mice as
weakly antitumor as a complete Rag deficiency.
And we learned about cross-presentation, which is
the induction of a CD8 T cell response to exogenous
antigen, and that this was missing.
Now importantly, Bob used these mice to show
that in the checkpoint blockade model that he studies in mice,
that even checkpoint blockade, PD-1 blockade
responses rely on the ability of the DC1 to be
there and to carry out priming of CD8 T cells.
So we started looking at DC1s and DC2s.
I'm just going to briefly point out that the major difference is the
level of a factor called IRF8. That's very high in the
DC1s. And we've studied the IRF8 gene in great
detail, and
I'm going to show just a couple of slides about the
mechanisms that we use to generate some model systems that have become very
useful. And these model systems are those that can
selectively lack one subset or another in the
mouse. So we identified three specific
enhancers in the IRF8 gene at 56, 41, and 32
kb downstream. And we defined that these are sequentially
used at different stages of myeloid development.
So the 56 is first, leads to the 41,
and finally, the 32 kb enhancer is
active right at the time when DC1s are
specified in the bone marrow by a transcription factor called
Innophile3.
What we discovered was that if you simply delete a few hundred base pairs
surrounding the binding sites for Batf3 and IRF8 at that
gene,
that you get a mouse that completely lacks DC1 development.
So this was a better model system than the
Batf3 because you're not
eliminating a transcription factor, just the specific site where that acts
on the critical gene that it controls.
And you can see that this mouse lacking those
sites in the IRF8 32 kb enhancer are completely
missing DC1s, and they never come back under
inflammatory settings like they can come back in the Batf3 knockout.
Now I'm going to show you, these are other model systems for DC2
heterogeneity, which are important from the immunological point of view of defense
against different pathogens. The first of those is Notch2
signaling, which occurs in the specified
pre-DC2 progenitor that comes out of the bone marrow and lands in peripheral
tissues. It can interact with Notch ligands, and this
was carried out by a student in the lab called Ansu
Satpathy. You can see here, carried out this work a few
years ago when he was a trainee in the lab.
And what this discovered was that the
terminal maturation of the DC2 into a
subset that can support defense against extracellular
bacteria and drive a TH17 response was completely
ablated when Notch was eliminated.
And you can see they become susceptible to this extracellular
pathogen
Citrobacter rodentium,
and
that's a selective deficiency.Now, there is another
function of the DC2s, and that's to support TH2 responses, and that seems
to be controlled by another transcriptional program in DC2s.
And one way to impair that is to delete the
transcriptional repressor Klf4.
And you can see over here in this
setting here that a certain subset called the
CD11blo subset of DC2s is
missing. And when that happens, you fail to be able to support a
TH2 response in several model systems.
And finally, we've made very recently a model system which deletes
both DC2 subsets. It deletes all
DC2s, and that's by targeting an enhancer of a factor called
Zeb2, its expression is required to
oppose DC1 development. So making specific mutations within the
Zeb2 enhancer, we call this the 123 mouse, you get rid
over here of almost all your DC2s. And these mice have, of course, a
defect in all the DC2-supported immune responses.
And this is an example where TH2 responses to hPolygyrs
are lost when the DC2s go missing. So the framework here
is still in flux. It's just a sketch
that we think that subsets exist to support
different modules of immunity, and somehow each of these DCs
is capable of responding appropriately, collecting the
antigen under different types of settings.
This is ongoing because we still don't know how everything works.
We're working on how cross-presentation actually works at the cellular
level, and I'll show you a couple of slides for that in a minute.
We don't understand everything about how the DC1 mediates help
for CD8 responses. That's mediated by the CD4 T
cell, for example, and we know that's probably a large part of that is
through CD27 signaling in the CD8 T cell.
But we don't know the specific mechanisms, and we don't
understand everything about how DC2 subsets develop and
how it is that they support different functions.
So that's all ongoing work. I want to say a few words
about cross-presentation. I won't go through the method. We cloned it.
This was a paper we published in 2018.
Genetics is powerful, but cell biology is hard.
So in 2018, we carried out
a CRISPR screen in primary dendritic cells for loss
of cross-presentation. And the hit we discovered was a
gene called WDFY4.
At that time, we didn't know what its structure was, but thanks to
DeepMind and Demis Hassabis' brilliance, we now can
guess that there's alpha solenoid or armadillo domains
that sandwich a Kane-like domain.
And this is 2,000 amino acids long.
And then the last thousand amino acids contains a characteristic PH
beach domain, a WD-40 motif,
and the total protein is about 3,100.
So this cDNA pushes the limits of what you can express in a retrovirus, and it's
been very challenging to
study. But this is work of Ray O'Hara and Derek Theisen,
Jesse, Nicole, and Luke Postow. But I'm going to show you a few slides from
some recent work that Ray O'Hara showed in his thesis.
So this is what happens when you have a WD deficiency.
This is an OT1 proliferation. That's the signal for
cross-presentation. WD deficient DC1s
can't do that.
And even soluble antigen, which really isn't
the hallmark of cross-presentation of cell-associated antigen,
that also loses some signal in the DC1s.
You become as poor as a DC2. Now, the important thing was
that WDFY4 is only expressed in DC1s
and a little bit in DC2s. It's not expressed in any other
cell type in the body.
But a germline knockout of WDFY4 leads to a complete
loss of antiviral, and this is a tumor, one of Bob
Schreiber's fibrosarcoma tumors, where you are completely
unable to make an anti-tumor response, and the DC1s
develop in this mouse, but they can't cross present.
So it's an important gene. This is
with Wayne Okuyama, an anti-cowpox tetramer response, and
WD is required for that as well. So it's
absolutely required for the cross-presentation of cell-associated antigen.
So we've been trying for many years to try to understand the cellular basis of this
requirement. What Ray has discovered is
that DC1s have
a large intracellular pool of class I MHC that is
not shared by DC2s shown on the
bottom and any other cell types that we have seen.
So it's a remarkable
discovery in the sense these are primary DC1s,
and you don't see this feature in cell lines
or other model systems that people use.
So
there's something unique about DC1s for the control of intracellular class
I.
So Ray went forward and made an N-terminal
FLAG-tagged version of WFY4,
and
I'm showing you here in green the intracellular using Neri
scan, which is not quite super-resolution microscopy, but is pretty high
resolution. And so you can see that the
DCs have this... The body would go way out here, but this
is the nucleus stained with DAPI blue, and the DC1s have this
unique characteristic cleft in the nucleus.
And this is where the WDFY4 stains, and you can see
it's sort of atubular shape
in the juxtanuclear position and
here's a high magnification. Here's the cleft and here's the
WDFY4.
And
so
this is a photograph of
macrophages and DC2s and DC1s, and we've given them
listeria, and the listeria has been labeled, that shows up purple in
this... And what you can see is listeria,
you can probably tell, collect tons of--
They just phagocytose most 99% of
the listeria is eaten by macrophages.
But you can see here a few cells that have this green spot.
You can tell a DC1 because it's the only cell that expresses
WDFY4. And they don't take up much listeria.
They take up a few. And here's an example of what happens.
They take up a listeria and the phagosomes are
transported towards this cluster of WDFY4
that's in that perinuclear cleft.
And I should say that we had studied a few years ago
a unique protein called Rab43. It's another protein
that is in the Rab family that is also DC1
specific. We made the knockout, and it did have an impaired
cross-presentation phenotype, and we didn't understand that as well.
But what I'm showing you here,
and I actually haven't shown you all the data, but Rab43 and
WDFY4
co-localize extremely highly in DC1s at
homeostasis. So the same tubular membranes that are
WDFY4 positive turn out to also be Rab43 positive.
And early, this is about two hours after uptake of listeria.
You can see the listeria has come up to approximate
this one organelle that's expressing WD
and FLAG.
I mean Rab43. A few hours later, what happens is
that you can look over here, the little blue dots.
Those are the nuclei of the listeria. So they've been taken up.
You can see that the listeria are still in purple,
but the FLAG, the WDFY4, and the
Rab43 have moved from that organelle where they were
originally over to surround the vesicles
that have captured the listeria. So we think that this
is evidence for what we prefer as the model
of cross-presentation to be a completely
vesicular non-cytosolic entry pathway for
cross-presentation. Our preference, our model is
that it's very similar
to class II processing for antigen, in which the
captured antigen remains within a vesicular compartment the entire
time and is eventually loaded onto class II.
We think that it's a very similar pathway, but using different
molecular chaperones. In our case, it relies on
Rab43 and WDFY4.
And we still need to work out the specific mechanisms of that.
So what I've talked to you so far about is
this diversity of dendritic cell subtypes,
which
play very specific roles. We are beginning
to understand how a DC1 becomes capable of driving
a CD8 response. It'll have something to do with the ability to capture
antigens from a dying cell. CLEC9a is one of the important
molecules there. Catana Esa Susa at the UK,
Kruk, has discovered this molecule, and it binds filamentous
actin of dying cells and would help capture
material from a tumor cell or a dying virally
infected cell.
So this is an example of a highly
specialized subset.
Now, I showed you we have these model systems where you don't have a
DC1 or you don't have a DC2, or you don't have this or that subset of
DC2s. And for reasons that are still a little
cloudy,
we began to ask the question about mRNA
vaccines. This came out,
I think we started this work in about 2023, and we were
prompted to
extend that work because of the recent interest
in clinical settings of using mRNA vaccines for
pancreatic immunotherapy. And so
since we had the mice and we understood a little bit
about the roles of different subsets in priming, we decided to
carry this work out. Now, this work that I'm going to talk about for the rest of
the meeting was just published last week,
and so I'll go through it, but it's still relatively
fresh, so
bear with me here. So the question really is how do mRNA vaccines
work for CD8 T cell responses? For antibody
responses, you expect that the generation of
antigen will somehow lead to a protective
antibody response. But in the case of
T cell vaccines, the question is what's the
mechanism and by what dendritic cell subset and
these types of things. So
this is an example
of a cDNA vaccine. This is the kind of thing that Will
Gilanders has worked on for a long time, and they were designed to specifically be
expressed in epithelial cells. So the antigen was
delivered through a gene gun apparatus,
transcribed
in those cells in the skin. And the antigens we showed a
long time ago were
producing a CD8 T cell response that is completely dependent
upon the DC1. So this is showing a cDNA vaccine
tetramer response in a wild type absent in a Delta 32, the one
missing the DC1s. And if you're missing DC2s, it doesn't do
anything. You still get it. So it's a DC1 specific CD8 T
cell response.You can take a soluble
protein and use this adjuvant, Adjuvants, and this also
is a fairly DC1-dependent immune
response. So these vaccines would be dependent upon the
DC1.
We were a little surprised when we used the same model system and used this
mRNA
LNP OVA expressing vaccine from Inovac that Will Gilanders
had obtained, and we see no loss
of tetramer response in any model system.
Meaning that it doesn't
depend on just a DC1 or a DC2.
We have the Wdfy4 knockout mouse, which I showed you earlier,
can't cross-present even though the DC1s are present.
And again, the tetramer response is
still
very proud. So it doesn't
require WD-dependent cross-presentation.
So the question would be, is there anything that's required?
Maybe muscle cells or macrophages are what are doing it.
So we wanted to test this.
Maybe dendritic cells aren't even required.
So to test that, we
used a system in which CD11c DTR,
if you treat the mice, you can eliminate all the dendritic
cells. These would be the conventional DCs here in a wild type are untreated,
and they disappear after treatment, and then the question is what
happens to the tetramer response?
So if you get rid of all classical dendritic cells through this treatment,
that gets rid of the tetramer response.
So at least we're on solid ground. At least
the response is a dendritic cell-dependent response,
but it doesn't care if it's a DC1 or a DC2.
Now I need to talk about the various ways that you can get antigen on a DC.
I've talked about cross-presentation, where exogenous antigen is captured
and put on, and we're trying to work out the cell biology of that.
If you directly express the antigen in the dendritic cell,
that can go through the TAP-dependent loading in the ER, and you can
express antigen. But there's a third way that's called MHC
dressing, or oftentimes called cross-dressing.
And this
is an unusual mechanism. We're not sure if this is the first
paper, but Mike Bevan, in 2011,
published this paper in "Nature" called "Cross-dressed dendritic cells
drive memory CD8 responses." So, and
I'll talk about what this actually is in a second, but
Stephanie Spranger,
just a couple of years ago, published a paper in which she had discovered
a very unusual tumor that turns out to make lots
of type I interferon. But the way she discovered that tumor is that it
was a tumor that was not dependent.
It could drive a CD8 T cell response independently
of DC1s, using either Batf3 knockout mice or Delta
32.
And so she
moved this issue of cross-dressing from just a
viral response into the tumor arena.
This is a slide generated by Gemini at about 10:35 this
morning,
in which I gave a very extensive prompt to try to make a slide
about what is cross-dressing. So
cross-dressing means that the peptide MHC
complex
starts on another cell and is transferred
to the surface of the dendritic cell by some unknown mechanism,
and people propose various mechanisms.
For us, it doesn't matter exactly what the mechanism is.
Stephanie Spranger's work said that whatever the mechanism is, it's dependent
upon type I interferons.
So we need
DCs, but do we need class I MHC on
DCs? So Suwen did this study. This is taking
CD11c Cre,
crossing it to the beta 2M flox. So that means that beta 2M will be
deleted from all classical dendritic cells.
If you look at the surface expression of class I, this is a normal surface
expression. This is a class I knockout.
But if you look at the Cre positive flox positive mice,
you can see that most of the dendritic cells have lost their surface
expression of class I. That's this purple bump here, and there's a
few
cells that express a little bit of surface class I.
And that's quantified here. But is that significant?
Well, it is significant. That class I that's missing from those
DCs is a sufficient loss to completely
block a tumor response, a
tetramer response. So I
call this Abelson M OVA. It's a tumor line that we made.
It expresses OVA, and it's a B cell tumor made by Abelson transformation.
So you get this induction of a tetramer,
of a OT1 proliferation, and that indicates that the wild
type DCs can cross-present this material.
If you take away class I from the DCs,
you don't get it. So that means that this loss of class I is sufficient
to kill most authentic cross-presented,
but not for mRNA vaccines. So here's the same mouse, this
guy over here, the
11C Cre across the beta 2M.
Even though you don't have much class I on the cell surface, the
mRNA vaccine still gives a big CD8
tetramer response. So that's pretty weird.
So where is the peptide MHC coming from?
I didn't believe this at first, but Suwen proved it to me by making a
series of bone marrow chimeras in which either wild type
or completely class I-deficient bone
marrow... is put into an irradiated recipient.
And now all of the dendritic cells in this mouse are either from the
wild type or in this case, the DCs themselves are
genetically deficient in class I MHC.
And
this here is to show you that that bone marrow chimer worked
perfectly. So all of the dendritic cells that are coming in these
mice are coming from the bone marrow.
But here's the point.
Here we're doing a specific control.
We're using a dead
mRNA vaccine as a control,
because this shouldn't give a response,
because it's not inducing antigen.
And in the wild type, that's true, it doesn't give an antigen.
But over here, the wild type, giving the normal mRNA vaccine gives you this
huge tetramer response. But now even in the bone marrow
chimera that doesn't have any class I
MHC genetically on the dendritic cell,
we're still getting about a third of the response for the
tetramer. Now, I don't know if one minus two
thirds is one third, but
this size of the response is
substantial.
So we would just guess or
speculate that a substantial amount of the
response in this model system of mRNA vaccine is actually
coming from a cross-dressed
MHC peptide complex from some other cell onto the dendritic
cell.
Okay, so I've told you that DC1s and DC2s
can
mediate the CD8 response. Why should we care who
primes a CD8 T cell? And the answer is
we should care because Bob Schreiber showed that it matters in another setting.
So he had published this paper in
2024, and this was a
substantial amount of work from his trainee, Hussein Sultan.
And what this paper showed was, in a model system
of
peptide-induced vaccination. So he has a class I
and a class II epitope in a tumor that has both class I
and class II neoantigens. And immunization
of the mice
using appropriate levels of peptide
can vaccinate those mice, and they give a clean rejection.
That's what this reject-- Here's the unvaccinated mice,
and if you vaccinate, you can clear the tumor.
What he discovered, sort of by accident, is if you give
too much of the class II epitope peptide,
that number one, DC2s start to present
the class II peptide to CD4 T cells.
And that this is a bad thing because in that setting
here or here,
the mice can't reject the tumor anymore.
And he proved that this was due to presentation by the
DC2 because he used our mouse that doesn't
have any DC2s. That's this Delta 123 in the black arrows
here. And those mice, even at the high dose treatment,
are able to prime. So DC2s
are not good
in this
model system. I'm going to skip that.
That's another Gemini
model slide, which didn't work out.
So the point is that
there are certain things to consider.
Now in our model system,
it doesn't matter when you use
in
vivo model systems.
Even though we're getting priming by DC2s
for the CD8 T cells, we can reject
a tumor. That's what's shown here and here.
So it's not like a completely ineffective CD8 T cell response.
But we wanted to know, are there any
differences where we might need to look in the future to see if there
are any more subtle differences between the CD8 T cells that
arise
when they're primed by a DC1 or abnormally primed by a
DC2? And that's in this experiment. This is the last experiment.
So CD8 T cells,
we have these mice. This mouse only has DC2s, and
this mouse only has DC1s.
And here's a wild type for a control.
And then we immunize with a dead
macro vaccine as a control. And so what we're doing here is we
immunize once, we immunize at day seven, and we're harvesting all
tetramer positive cells at day 11.
So four days after the second immunization.
And we took these cells, and we did, in collaboration with
Naresh Saligrama and his postdoc, Chandri Thakur,
we did a big single-cell RNA seq analysis.
And
generally, if you lump them all together, we see naive and memory populations
which migrate to a stem-like, some people would call it
a Tpex, but it's a stem-like population.
And then the effector populations are in red, and the cycling
effectors are in these shades of blue.
So,
first of all,
we carried out just a global comparison
between the different fractions of these populations, between
wild type Delta 32 and the 123. So you can
see the wild type, and when you're primed by either wild
type or only primed by DC2s, those look fairly
similar. But if you're primed by a DC1, you have a
greater expansion of fewer effectors and more
cycling
effectors.And I think it's easier to show
this here,
that the red ones are the effectors.
So you get these effectors, but if you're only
primed by the ones you should be primed by, by the DC1, you get a better
proliferative
capacity of your early effectors.
You get a greater
population of your stem-likes and fewer effector cells.
So I'm going to end there. Here are my take-home
messages. mRNA vaccines engage both DC1s and
DC2s. They break all the rules. You don't need WDFY4.
And a substantial amount of this priming occurs by
cross-dressing.
We still don't know whether or not the quality of the CD8
T cells is going to be a problem, whether the ones
primed by DC2s might have weaker memory
responses, for example.
And there's still a lot of work to do.
So I've just run out of time, and I'm going to stop there.
Thank all the people who did this work again, thank the
AACR and the CRI for this award, and on behalf of these
people who did the work, and take any questions.
Thank you very much.
If there are any questions for Ken, it's not the
normal practice, but Ken is not normal scientist.
Yeah.
Anyway, incredible scientist. Quick question.
So what do you think, are any DCs
expressing protein off of mRNA that gets inside
their cells, or it's entirely expressed by surrounding cells?
Okay.
Well, I should say that
we suspect that there's a substantial amount of
direct expression by the dendritic cell.
So there's a lot of cross-dressing going on.
You can see that only when you take away the class one from the DCs,
that genetic experiment. But I would guess that
a substantial amount of the additional response is
due to direct
uptake of the mRNA and expression within DC2s and DC1s.
So Ken, does the route or the dose of mRNA
impact whether or not you get adequate priming via
cross-dressing?
I didn't catch the first part of that.
Does the-
Does the route-
The route
... of administration or the dosing-
Right
... of administration?
Yeah. These are all important questions.
Of course,
I know that I've talked with Stephanie Spranger, and I've
talked with Mike Diamond,
and they have vaccines
for membrane-tethered antigens.
This was a soluble antigen because that's what they're using in the clinical
trials, is a soluble neoantigenette cassette.
Different forms of antigen,
at least in other people's hands, seem to give a greater
DC1 dependence. It's not absolute, so they use the same mice.
They're using our mice.
But they see at least a reduction in the tetramer response
in the DC1 deficient. So in some settings, the immunization
may give a CD8 response that's
proper, DC1 dependent, so nothing to worry about.
The other thing is that the amount of cross-dressing that's occurring
could be substantially influenced by the particular lipid composition, which could
influence how much type I interferon is made in response to the
vaccine.
We've tested our own membrane-tethered OVA,
which was one of the possibilities for why theirs might be
DC1 dependent, partially
DC1 dependent, and we still see no DC1 dependence
in the membrane-tethered version of the OVA
antigen.
One of the points is that I think that it might be
worrisome to have cross-dressing as part of your vaccine treatment
if you're treating a non-lethal disease, because cross-dressing
could cause
the transference of a self-epitope to which you're not responsive
normally to a dendritic cell, and now you're getting priming.
There are instances, rare cases of myocarditis after
COVID vaccination. They don't persist,
but this type of thing is something to consider.
But yes, route probably matters, and
one of the features that we noticed in this study, which is in the paper, is
that in our hands, intramuscular injection leads
to
immunogenicity at distant sites.
A lot of studies looked at the
amount of antigen, just looking at antigen quantity,
and it's mostly concentrated right at the vaccination site.
But ours is the only study that actually looked for
immune
responsiveness by taking OT-1 that's parked in
different places and seeing if they actually respond, and we see
responses in distant sites. So it's immunogenic at
distant sites. Now we don't know if that is
migration of the viral particle before it transfects a cell or movement
of the antigen through the bloodstream. We just don't know that yet.
Just one more aspect of that. Have you looked at
some of the weaker variants of synfecl and seen whether or
not those weaker variants actually also can get cross-presented?
No, we haven't yet.
Okay.
We haven't yet. No.
Hi. Thank you for the lecture. So
do you know if B cells play any role in this
cross-dressing or in the extent of-
Now that's a great question
... the response?
We don't know.
We haven't been able to design experiments to
identify where the cross-dressed
cells are coming from. That's going to take some work, but I think it's an
important question to ask. It could be macrophages. It could be B cells.
Could be somatic cells. We don't know yet.
Thank you.
Well, if there are no further questions, thank you all
for coming, for attending this very special session.
Congratulations to Ken
once again, and thank you for a great lecture.